in 2013
i was an executive at an international
engineering firm in san francisco
it was my dream job a culmination of all
the skills that i've acquired over the
years
storytelling social impact behavior
change i was the head of marketing and
culture
and i work with the nation's largest
healthcare systems
using technology and culture change to
radically reduce
their energy water use and to improve
their social impact
i was creating real change in the world
and it was the worst professional
experience of my life
i hit the glass ceiling hard it hurt
like hell
while there were bigger issues most of
what happened were little behaviors
and little behaviors and patterns that
slowly
chipped away at my ability to do my work
well
they ate away at my confidence my
leadership my capacity to innovate
for example my first presentation at the
company
i walk up to the front of the room to
give a presentation on the strategy that
i believe is right for the company
the one they hired me to create and i
look around the room at my fellow
executives
and i watch as they pick up their cell
phones and look down at their laptops
they're not paying attention
as soon as i start to speak the
interruptions begin and people talk over
me again
and again and again some of my ideas
are flat out dismissed and then brought
up by somebody else and
championed
i was the only woman in that room and i
could have used an ally
little behaviors and patterns like this
every day again and again
they wear you down pretty soon my energy
was
absolutely tapped at a real low point
i read an article about toxic workplace
culture and microaggressions
microaggressions everyday slights
insults
negative verbal and non-verbal
communication whether intentional or not
that impede your ability to do your work
well
that sounded familiar i started to
realize
that i wasn't failing the culture around
me
was failing me and i wasn't alone
behaviors and patterns like this every
day affect underrepresented people of
all backgrounds in the workplace and
that has a real
a real impact on our colleagues on our
companies
and our collective capacity to innovate
so in the tech industry we want quick
solutions but there is no magic wand
for correcting diversity and inclusion
change happens one person at a time one
act at a time
one word at a time we make a mistake
when we see diversity and inclusion as
that side project over there the
diversity people are working on
rather than this work inside all of us
that we need to do together
and that work begins with unlearning
what we know about success and
opportunity
we've been told our whole lives that if
we work hard that hard work pays off we
get
what we deserve we live our dream but
that isn't true for everyone
some people have to work 10 times as
hard to get to the same place
due to many barriers put in front of
them by society
your gender your race your ethnicity
your religion
your disability your sexual orientation
your class
your geography all of these can give you
more or fewer opportunities for success
and that's where allyship comes in
allyship
is about understanding that imbalance
and opportunity and working to correct
it
allyship is really seeing the person
next to us
and the person missing who should be
standing next to us
and first just knowing what they're
going through and then
helping them succeed and thrive with us
when we work together to develop more
diverse and inclusive teams
data shows we will be more innovative
more productive and more profitable
so who is an ally all of us we can all
be allies for each other
as a white cisgendered woman in the
united states there are many ways i'm
very privileged
and some ways i'm not and i work hard
every day to be an ally for people with
less privilege than me
and i still need allies too
in the tekken in the tech industry like
in many industries there are many people
who are underrepresented or face
barriers and discrimination
women people who are non-binary so
people who don't necessarily identify as
man or woman
racial and ethnic minorities lgbtqia
people with disabilities
veterans anybody over age 35.
we have a major bias toward youth in the
tech industry
and many others there is always someone
with less privilege than you
on this stage in this room at your
company on your team
in your city or town
so people are allies for different
reasons find your reason
it could be for the business case
because data shows
diverse and inclusive teams will be more
productive more profitable and more
innovative
it could be for fairness and social
justice
because we have a long history of
oppression
and inequity that we need to that we
need to work on
together or it could be for your kids so
your cr
your kids grow up with equal
opportunities and they grow up
creating equal opportunities for others
find your reason for me it's all three
find your reason
and step up to be there for someone who
needs you
so what can you do as an ally start by
doing no harm
it's our job as allies to know what
microaggressions are
and to not do them it's our job as
allies
to listen to learn to unlearn and
to relearn and to make mistakes and to
keep learning
give me your full attention
close your laptops put down your cell
phones and pay attention
if somebody is new or the only person in
the room like them or they're just
nervous
this is going to make a huge difference
in how they show up
don't interrupt underrepresented people
are more likely to be interrupted so
just take a step back and listen
echo and attribute if i have a great
idea
echo my idea and then attribute it to me
and we thrive together
learn the language i use to describe my
identity
know how to pronounce my name know my
pronouns he
she they know the language i use to
describe my disability my ethnicity
my religion this
really matters to people so if you don't
know just ask
listen and learn an executive told me
recently that after doing
allyship on his team
the whole team started to normalize
calling themselves out and each other
out
for interrupting i'm so sorry i'm
interrupting you right now
carry on hey she's got a great idea
let's listen number two
advocate for underrepresented people in
small ways
intervene you can change the power
dynamics in the room
if you see somebody is the only person
in the room like them
and they're being belittled they're
being interrupted do something
say something invite underrepresented
people to speak
and say no to panels without
underrepresented
speakers refer someone for a job
and encourage them to take that job and
to take new opportunities
and this one's really important help
normalize allyship
if you're a person with privilege it's
easier for you
to advocate for allies so use that
privilege
to create change three change someone's
life significantly
so be there for somebody throughout
their career
mentor or sponsor them give them
opportunities as they grow
volunteer volunteer for a stem program
serving underserved youth
transform your team to be more diverse
and inclusive and make
real commitments to creating change here
hold yourself
and your team accountable for creating
change
and lastly help advocate for change
across your company when companies teach
their people to be allies
diversity and inclusion programs are
stronger you and i
can be allies for each other whether
we're inside or outside of work
so i realized recently
that i still have lingering shame and
fear
from that moment in my career when i
felt utterly alone
shut out and unsupported there are
millions of people out there like me
right now feeling that way and it
doesn't take much
for us to be there for each other and
when we're there for each other when we
support one another
we thrive together and when we thrive
we build better teams better products
and better companies
allyship is powerful try it
thank you
you